[Music]
brand-new tonight Politico out with an
explosive report about potential deep
state spying on a former top trump
adviser here's their headline FBI
surveillance of Carter page might have
picked up Bannon now according to the
reporting Carter page was being
surveilled by the FBI last January
during the presidential transition when
Paige had a phone call about Russia with
former White House chief strategist
Steve Bannon according to Politico Paige
made this shocking revelation during
congressional testimony and Paige said
at the time the banning called him about
cancelling a planned television
appearance and then Paige eventually
brought up the phony dossier which
BuzzFeed had published us the day
earlier On January 10th now it's not
certain if the conversation with banham
was picked up by the FBI but national
security experts they're telling
Politico that it's very possible that it
did happen now investigative reporter
Cheryl Atkinson who says the Obama
administration you may remember remember
they she said they hacked her computer's
made this very profound point on the
show earlier this week let's take a look
at this I was told even before a Donald
Trump announced for office that Intel
officials and I was told this by
insiders have sometimes been using bad
information to bring to the FISA Court
to wrap up other people that are the
true targets that they can't get a
warrant against but to wrap them up in
incidental targeting different ways
without may be a direct warrant wow this
is beyond shocking and it's raising some
very serious questions given the other
information that we already know now
according to two Republican memos the
FBI lie to the FISA Court remember they
used a Clinton bought and paid for
Russian dossier they never verified or
corroborated it in order to get a
warrant to spy on Carter Paige now
remember the Grassley Graham memo that
detailed how Comey never bothered to
verify all this anti-trump information
in the dossier that Christopher Steele
had put together because he thought well
the former British spy was credible in
the past now that same memo also
uncovers how the bulk of the fight
application the FBI presented to the
FISA judge consisted of the dossier that
they never verified this is unbelievable
and we also know that Comey told them
president-elect Trump that the dossier
was salacious and unverified during the
transition that was what two months
before and the dossier was good enough
to get a FISA warrant but it was
unverified and salacious this entire
scandal now reeks of corruption beyond
anything which we have seen before in
other words what he's admitting here
what we're seeing here is the powerful
tools that we give our intelligence
community to protect us with abuse to
spy on an opposition campaign during an
election and before an election and
after an election now also tonight Fox
News has obtained House Intelligence
Committee chairman Devin Nunez has
letter requesting transcripts of Carter
pages FISA Court hearings this is
important now chairman Nunez is asking
for quote any relevant FISA Court
hearings associated with the initial
FISA application or subsequent renewals
related to electronic surveillance of
Carter page I'd like to see them too now
the house committee is setting a
February 16th deadline that's one week
from tonight for the court to provide
those transcripts if they in fact have
them now getting these transcripts would
be a massive development because as we
have been explaining night after night
we know the top echelon of the FBI
again they relied almost exclusively on
this hillary clinton bought and paid for
dossier to get that warrant and then of
course on carter page and they didn't
tell the FISA Court that the dossier was
in fact bought and paid for with about
12 million dollars of monies paid for by
Hillary Clinton and the DNC funneled
through the same law firm now we're
following this developing story because
this is key in all of this how could you
use an unverified Russian propaganda
dossier to get a FISA warrant to spy on
an opposition candidate and an incoming
president all right also other breaking
news this hour another new explosive
report according to ABC News Senate
investigators they are
a second anti-trump dossier now this was
put together by longtime Clinton ally
guy by the name of Cody Shearer and
according to ABC the Senate Intelligence
Committee is now trying to set up an
interview with Shearer who reportedly is
claiming that he put together the second
dossier as quote an independent
journalist now nobody's buying that
because according to the Guardian
Shearer has ties going all the way back
to when Bill Clinton was president in
the 90s and we did reach out to Shearer
for comment shocking he didn't get back
to us and we're also learning tonight
that the State Department was in fact
involved in obtaining and then spreading
phony anti-trump information during the
campaign really and a former top ranking
official at the department that Hillary
Clinton used to run is admitting in a
Washington Post op-ed that he was in
contact with Christopher Steele also and
that Clinton confidante said vicious
Blumenthal gave him information that
came from Cody Shearer who we just told
you about now this is a striking
admission from the State Department
because remember
Christopher Steele used the information
it was never never verified Clinton paid
for it
her friends are feeding Steele nobody
verifies it and then it's used as a
basis for a FISA warrant and you got
this guy Jonathan Winer it matches
exactly what the memo put together by
senators Grassley and Graham exposed
earlier this week when we got the
unredacted version and of course we have
congressman debe Nunez well he told us
in an interview earlier this week that
his committee is now investigating the
State Department and their involvement
in this now in an op-ed entitled Devin
Nunez is investigating me here's the
truth well whiner says that he met with
Christopher Steele in Washington in
September 2016 to talk about information
in the dossier after which whiner goes
on to explain about the dossier quote I
was allowed to review but not to keep a
copy of these reports to enable me to
alert the State Department I prepared it
two-page summary I shared it with
Newland who indicated that like me she
felt the Secretary of State needed to be
aware of this material so former Obama
Secretary of State John Kerry may
also be involved in the scandal which is
why he needs to now answer questions
under oath about what he knew when he
knew it and if he ever saw this dossier
what he knew about the dossier
now Winer then goes on to write how
later that month that he talked with his
friend Sid Vicious Blumenthal best
friend of the Clintons and Winer admits
quote he talking about blooming Paul
showed me notes gathered by a journalist
I didn't know Cota Shearer that alleged
the Russians had compromising
information on Trump of a sexual and
financial nature and what struck me was
how some of these materials
Echo's steals but appeared to involve
different sources so why nerd thing goes
on to write on my own I shared a copy of
these notes with Steele to ask for his
professional reaction he told me it was
potentially collateral information and I
asked him what he meant by that and he
said that it was similar but separate
from the information he had gathered
from his sources by the way Russian
sources then he writes I agreed to let
him keep a copy of the Shearer notes a
winder goes on to say the Christopher
Steele shared the information that he
gave him to the FBI
DCO unbelievable this is now we reached
out to Blumenthal for comment he's not
responding to our requests so this whole
scandal starts with Hillary Clinton
remember rigging the primary against
Bernie Sanders why Bernie people aren't
more mad I don't know then she tried to
rig the general election against Donald
Trump she pays for a phony Russian
propaganda dossier filled with Russian
government lies and propaganda the FBI
then takes that bought and paid for
dossier they don't tell the FISA judge
the truth to go out and get a warrant to
spy on the Trump campaign before the
election and then they use it after the
election and there's now concerns that
Steve Bannon former top trump aide well
that he might have been caught up in
incidental surveillance oh by the way
there might be a lot of other people and
we're also learning that in addition to
the Clinton campaign well we have
Hillary's allies they're feeding anti
Trump dirt to the State Department which
is sharing it with Christopher Steele
like we've been telling you sit
if you think this is bad right now I
promise you it's going to only get worse
what we have now is a sliver of the
information it's coming out day by day
I've been warning you from the beginning
this is Watergate on steroids and as you
can see this gets more corrupt by the
day